all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back with invincible yes
we are now picking up after the last
video there's a couple things a few
things we need to follow up with the
first is that given that zandale who was
kind of the replacement uh invincible
while mark was basically off in space
because he had allied with rex robot and
it basically turned against the
superhero community he had actually
orchestrated the capture of those
superheroes who had effectively gone
underground and so this basically led to
them being snatched up rounded up right
taken back to the pentagon where they
were basically being held prisoner and
so on and so forth but then you ended up
finding out that sinclair had actually
because he stood against what rex robot
was doing had actually helped him to
escape and then in turn fired up a
rocket and seemingly just took off into
space right we don't know exactly what
it is that happened to him but where all
these guys were basically hidden out
where they were essentially removed
didn't really want to have a whole lot
of involvement here sort of just kind of
staying hidden this basically led to rex
robot figuring out where they were at
now of course the crazy thing about this
is rex basically says like look i've got
eyes and ears everywhere right like i
mean it was only a matter of time before
i found you guys you couldn't have
stayed hidden forever the other thing
about this is that instead of
approaching it from a place of violence
he actually approaches them and says
look i get that you guys want to fight
against this i get that you guys want to
fight against this change and what it is
that i'm doing here but look around you
people have never been safer right crime
is down all that stuff right the world
is categorically a safer place because
of what i've done what you are doing is
you are trying to maintain the status
quo of the world being a chaotic mess
probably for no other reason than to
justify your existence because what
purpose do you serve if the world is
saved suddenly you have no purpose right
you just find yourself just flying
headfirst into an existential crisis and
so that's the thing like making this
compelling argument and saying like i've
improved everything i've made everything
better people are happier than they used
to be a lot of them actually end up
siding with rex and just kind of being
like yeah i mean there's a lot more that
we can do right there's a lot of things
that can be done to basically fix this
and to make the world a better place and
so there's no real fight to be had here
there's no real major conflict he was
like for those of you guys who want to
stand against me okay that's fine right
but in time you will see how i've made
this world a better place and in time
you will you will come to me you know
he's like i'll allow you to take you
know take some time to figure out what
it is that you want to do without me
hunting you down or attacking you unless
you come after me right if you come
after me then we have a problem but take
the time you need now what this is is
really him just saying like i will come
back at a future point in time and when
that happens we will make a decision
like we'll we'll determine whether or
not you're gonna stand against me or
with me if you stand against me then
we're enemies and i will hunt you down
and i will kill you if you stand with me
then we're good right so like just take
the time you need to figure it out and
so following that there's a couple
things that go on here in terms of
leaving earth because at this point we
kind of leave earth and we don't really
come back for a little while one of the
first things you do is you basically
pick up with a coalition of planets and
without the alien addressing the rest of
the coalition members and one of the
things about this is you know when it
comes to if you guys ever watch like
these these kind of like sci-fi movies
or you ever watch politics or anything
like that oftentimes there's a lot of
veiled threats right a lot of illusions
to the fact that like things are about
to get really really bad for a
particular person an example of this is
when alan is talking about how they are
basically diverting as many of their
forces as they can to track down thrack
so long is thrag right so long as
freddie mercury exists out there in
space he will never stop trying to
rebuild his vilturmite army and he will
never stop trying to hunt down the
coalition of worlds destroy them and
then in turn bring the quote-unquote
vulture might race back to a state of
glory right like he will never stop
doing that but that's when one of the
members of the coalition basically
chimes in and says okay our report from
the space racer who's basically a spy
out there keeping an eye on on what it
is that freddie mercury is doing he's
reported back that freddie mercury is
basically like he chose the planet
mantia and has chosen that because of
the genetic makeup of its people they
age faster and they are closely in line
with the viltrumite race it allows him
to build his own army and of course the
response of alan alien is like yes we
already know that like we already know
that's what's going on you know that i
know that right and we as the reader
know that because we've literally been
covering it the reason why this is
brought up by this council member is
that she says sure i mean it's a worthy
task to try to track down thrag but why
not just use the the the nature of that
race or a race similar to it to build up
our own army right like why can't we
just turn mantia into a breeding farm
one that's twice as productive and build
our own army so we can overcome them and
the response of the alien is no like i
am not a fan of conquering a world and
using it as a breeding colony in order
to ensure that we somehow defeat freddie
mercury and his own race now this is an
important thing because this is an
option for success that's being
presented to allen alien and notice he's
turning it down at that point some of
the members of the council i mean it's
almost kind of split 50 50. not all of
them agree with this council member's
proposal but some of them do and that's
important because what this does is this
is going to start sowing the seeds of
resentment that if things start going
south people are going to think back to
options that alan the alien was getting
and because of his moral high ground
refused to accept them and the reality
is that when it comes to fighting wars
there is no room for the moral high
ground there's the people who win and
the people who lose and that's it the
morality of a dead man is irrelevant in
the face of the victor because history
is written by the victor so the morality
of that loser doesn't matter
it's irrelevant right the people who win
wars are the ones who live long enough
to win them that's the thing and so it's
one of those interesting concepts is
because at that point alan the alien
when he's visited by by one of the
members of the council who's like look
you know they were totally out of place
for suggesting that just know alan not
everybody on the council is against you
that's the veiled threat because a
veiled threat is there are people on the
council who don't want you here they
think that you're not a very effective
leader right they're basically working
against you right that's the thing to
understand and so that really kind of
lingers over alan allen alien's head
right like heavy is the head that wears
the crown that some people when you're
leading a massive coalition like that
some people are going to want to see you
fail and for no other reason than the
fact that the way you conduct business
is totally different than the way that
they would do it and they think they can
do it better right other times it's
because you really are just an inept
leader right it just depends on the
situation
depends on the context but the thing
about that is ultimately uh allen
basically has this kind of conversation
with mark and oliver where he basically
says look so word has reached our ears
that that basically space racer has
managed to track down what's going on
with uh with thrack and we need you guys
to go there and take him out like we've
located him we need you guys to remove
him from the board hopefully space razor
hasn't been detected hopefully nobody
knows he's there only for us to find out
he was detected and freddie mercury has
basically killed him but it's one of
those things where mark essentially has
to kind of leave things behind yet again
now again this is just part of the this
is the nature of the beast right it's
kind of the agreement that was struck
between mark and adam eve in the sense
that like if they're here that sure he
won't necessarily be operating on earth
in the same way that he was that you
know that he did before but there will
be times where he has to leave to go on
a mission right it's just the nature of
a job and so the result of this is that
they kind of came to an agreement of
okay right just don't be gone too long
and so what this does of course is it
leads to mark and oliver and all these
different forces basically taking off
and ultimately tracking down uh freddie
mercury's location only to find out that
once they get there he's seemingly not
there right and in fact there's no
indication they were ever there right
literally they just disappeared right
they just vanished and so they're like
okay that means that if they killed
space racer then they have to know that
we're on to them so sure i guess it
would make sense that they would
basically just up and leave ultimately
they end up finding one of the spies and
the problem is that this spy is
basically a coward right they're like
what are we paying you for because he's
like i don't know what happened man i
mean i know it was like a great huge
fight with space racer and all those
guys but when the fight broke out i just
ran and hit and it's just like dude
you have no balls man like a total
coward in that way but what he does say
is that uh is that they were you know
when he came out of hiding they were all
basically gone but his response is i'm
not really sure they actually left this
place i'm not sure they left this planet
they could be virtually anywhere and so
what it does is it leads to oliver and
the forces of of you know the coalition
of planets basically searching the
surface and it leads to mark searching
the subterranean realm now this is where
things get crazy because when this
happens mark basically seems to fall
down what seems like this infinite well
right like just this giant hole like he
just kind of you know something's like
actually pulling him down into this
place that he can't avoid and when he
gets down to where this is he's met by
what seems like this giant kind of uh
you know light light based thing
construct organism or whatever which
engulfs mark and then mark wakes up back
home on earth the entire continuity of
invincible basically just got rebooted
and that's a crazy thing is because at
that point mark's trying to figure out
what in the world is going on right he's
like okay so this is weird like i'm
basically waking up at this moment and
omni man is like facing off against the
dragon like it all feels very familiar
right and so one of the things and this
this was kind of interesting uh really
this gets fast-tracked we don't really
get like a we don't have robert kirkman
giving us like a whole great big huge
set of events instead a lot of the stuff
gets fast-tracked because there is a
point to the end of all this so mark
basically goes to school and he visits
adam eve right right off the bat he says
okay like i know who you are uh i know
that you're basically adam eve i know
you have powers all that kind of stuff
we need to talk like we need to have a
conversation in effect like he tells her
like i know you're part of the team team
and i know all that stuff rex and
duplicate and everything i know
everything that's going on and initially
the only reason why adam eve even brings
him to the location of the teen team is
because at that point it's like okay we
need to know what's going on with this
guy like we need to understand what's
happening with this guy and literally he
just spills the beans like one of the
things he tells robot is like you're not
even a robot right like you were born
deformed you're in a lab across town you
live through this robot construct your
name is basically rudy and so where
where no one else on the teen team knows
this and it's just like okay man
whatever like at this point you're just
being kind of nuts that's crazy the
responsive robot is no it's actually
true nobody was supposed to know that
none of you are supposed to know that
like those of you guys who recall like
who've been following us all this time
remember the story way back when where
basically that pissed off professor
whose son was bullied and ended up going
crazy was basically turning the students
into human bombs that guy's arrested
before anything ever actually happens
right rex is still there of course with
with adam e right the two of them are
still knocking boots but basically what
mark starts doing here is he starts
going through and trying to rectify all
these different problems all these
mistakes right he tries to save as many
lives as humanly possible now the big
elephant in the room here is of course
omni man it's nolan because this is this
is way back when this is before the
fight broke out between mark and nolan
this is before anybody became aware of
the fact that nolan was actually a
viltromite or any of that stuff this is
all the way back at the very beginning
of the story mark being thrown back here
into the past is basically him just kind
of being like okay how am i going to
confront my dad with the fact that i
know he's a viltromite i know he's been
sitting here to conquer the world and i
need to find a way to stop him right how
is that going to happen but but along
the way here it's literally him getting
his costume from like the the suitor
right the guy who designs costumes to
everybody picking his costume right off
the bat um it's him facing off against
like the mauler twins it's them busting
sinclair when he was making robots right
it's basically him capturing and busting
all these different villains before
anything pops off right when the zacks
will start showing up here right that
alien race like when they start arriving
here and basically you know it's it's
well through a whole lot of casualties
they end up realizing the longer they're
here on earth the faster they age that
what mark starts saying is just hold
them in place right like hold them in
place don't die they will age up
exceedingly fast right like it's just
that's just how their race works right
time passes differently in their
dimension than it does here they will
age rapidly and initially people don't
necessarily believe him but ultimately
they do now if you guys recall in that
fight basically man showed up you know
the the whole fight and conflict and
everything went nuts and then he ended
up being trapped inside that that racist
dimension uh instead mark stops him and
it's like okay so uh yeah like like when
when omni man's like do you have powers
mark's like yeah right because remember
when omniman learned mark had powers it
didn't happen this way and so when the
two of them start talking in the end uh
his father is like you know why why
wouldn't you tell me that you have
powers right you know he's like well i
was trying to figure out how to tell you
he's like we need to go talk outside and
so what he does is he is is the two of
them flying to the sky it's probably one
of the best moments in all of invincible
the two of them flying in the sky and
mark starts talking to nolan and he's
like you know first things first i need
to know do you love me and do you love
debbie right do you do you love my mom
and the response of nolan is of course i
do like why wouldn't i like why would i
not love you or your mom i love you guys
with all my heart you guys mean the
world to me like you're both extremely
important to me and he says okay
please
don't conquer the planet earth at that
point nolan freaks right and just
immediately starts attacking mark now
well i guess it doesn't do it
immediately like mark basically explains
he was like here's what's going to
happen next right first now that you
know i have powers and our people can
create offspring that have powers with
people of this planet you start making
plans to take over you kill the
guardians of the globe because you know
they could slow you down or maybe even
stop you then you come to me and ask me
to help you you tell me you've been
lying this whole time and why you were
really sent here and then you asked me
to turn on mom and all the people on
earth and i refuse i try to talk simpson
to you to talk you out of it but you
won't listen and then we fight and you
nearly kill me but right before you do
you stop you become an internet meme and
then later you tell me that you
hesitated because you realize how much
you love mom and me eventually we rebel
against the viltrumide empire together
and we win i don't know what's going
through your head right now but can we
just keep talking this over i know all
of this sounds crazy but i don't want to
fight again i really don't want to and
at that point the fight's on like
literally nolan just starts attacking
mark now mark tries to like talk him
down but he's like no right and he's
just like no you have like mark's like
you have to understand we're going to
turn against the villager might race
it's what we're supposed to do and the
response of nolan is i'm no traitor like
i am not a person who's going to turn
against the viltromide empire that's
never going to be the case right my
loyalty is to the vulture might race
i've been with them for thousands of
years this is never going to change and
so he's like okay i probably you know so
mark basically races off he's like i
probably should have thought about this
better but instead of the fight taking
place the way it originally did it is a
pretty intense fight but there's other
things to also keep in mind here mark
being sent back here is seemingly just
as capable as he was before maybe not
necessarily in terms of physical
strength but in terms of battle strategy
in terms of how to engage with someone
like omni man and so where nolan catches
up to him of course because nolan's not
really paying attention they basically
end up fighting and uh they end up crash
landing and that's when that's what
nolan says like i won't stop until i've
beaten some sins into you this planet's
fate was decided the moment our people
discovered it we'd only assure its
demise by trying to save it and that's
when you end up finding out that what
mark had done is he had actually led
omniman to the to the home base of the
guardians of the globe so instead of
omniman killing the guardians of the
globe without them suspecting it like he
did in the main invincible timeline
instead here they've learned he's a
traitor now of course a massive fight
breaks out and to a degree it goes the
way you would expect right i mean we
knew that nolan was for the most part
way beyond the other members of the
guardians of the globe but what nolan
has in terms of strength and speed the
guardians make up for in terms of
numbers and that's one of the things
right i mean there does come a point
when you just have kind of like
diminishing returns where a person is
just so incredibly strong that no amount
of forces you throw at them will be able
to overcome them but if the forces you
have are relatively comparable in power
even if the power they have is in
varying degrees it is entirely possible
they could overtake that person and
that's basically what happens with nolan
right mark is just kind of knocked out
of the way and then the fight breaks out
between like nolan and the immortal and
all those guys the immortal gets a hole
punched in but because he's basically
immortal of course you'll end up
surviving and the other members of the
guardians all basically end up stepping
in and so this basically leads to them
essentially overcoming nolan right i
mean they basically managed to knock him
out and that's essentially it right i
mean they don't really kill him probably
they don't really have the strength or
the ability to kill him but regardless
they're able to knock him unconscious
now while they do chain him up of course
they also say like this is not going to
hold him as soon as he wakes up he's
just going to immediately break free of
these chains as if they weren't there at
all and then the fight's going to be
back on again but ultimately because the
guardians of the globe work directly
with cecil what ends up happening is
basically cecil steps in and when that
happens essentially omni man is taken by
cecil right he's basically in prison now
of course mark spills the beans on the
history of his relationship with cecil
right basically in forming cecil here's
everything that's going on right here's
how we worked together and all that kind
of stuff and so nolan's basically taking
prisoner and captain stasis and so
what's nuts about this is that
everything is starkly different in a lot
of ways marcus come out on top here
right he's basically the good guy he's
saved countless lives and all that
really comes to a head after his
conversation with nolan uh where nolan
says like thank you for for doing this
right like when you when you were like
spilling the beans and you were telling
what was going on i lost my cool but i
basically went nuts uh but ultimately
you managed to talk me down and that's
basically it and so what this does is it
essentially leads to seemingly nolan
being taken by alan the alien once alan
alien first arrives on the scene uh
presumably being taken back to the
coalition of worlds only for us to find
out that's not really what it is right
that instead nolan basically you know
talks with debbie kind of basically
spills the beans to her for a little bit
and then ends up siding with alan the
alien so in a lot of ways things have
essentially turned out the same way just
seemingly by different means but what
this did is it saved the lives of
countless people in the process one
thing to remember there have been
millions upon millions of people who
have died in the various conflicts that
have taken place over the course of the
invincible story so far right it's just
been in a lot of ways absolute
pandemonium and absolute chaos with the
guardians of the globe really just like
the team team that that mark basically
goes forward in like finding various
villains and like snatching them up
preventing them from being like a
credible threat to anybody and like
that's basically it one of the big
crushing blows that goes on here is that
mark never actually forms a relationship
with adam eve right that never really
happens he saves her a few times and you
know she thinks he's cute but like she's
with rex right and she's loyal right i
mean she's loyal to rex even though he's
kind of a dick right she doesn't really
see a reason to like run off with mark
because mark saved her from like some
threat that she probably could have
saved herself from right and so what
ends up happening is mark has it really
just kind of kind of you know collapses
under the weight of where he is right in
the sense that like him and adam eve
never get together it's emotionally
crushing and that's when he's met by the
return of this kind of blinding white
life and this is huge right this is a
really really big moment because he's
like he's like you're that thing from
the cave like what in the hell are you
and what this thing says is that is not
important do you not realize how many
you have saved you have undone so much
death and misery why are you not pleased
and mark's response is my life sucks
right like my life is worse than it was
before and they say your changes have
ripple effects something you did
prevented e from catching rex and kate
together but we read you we know you
mark grayson why would you trade those
who died simply to maintain your
relationship and the response of mark is
yes you're right right like i mean it
wouldn't really make any sense to do
that like why would i why would i trade
the lives of people for the relationship
that i'm in and this thing says you have
already sacrificed so much that is why
we chose you you are the only one we've
encountered who could set things right
there is a balance to the universe and
it has been disrupted somewhere along
the way things went wrong too many
innocents have basically died we have
seen the world change in their absence
we exist outside of time we see all at
once you touch so many your influence is
vast we saw that if you were set on
another path the balance would be
restored but you have to choose this
world you inhabit your past it is very
real the world you knew is gone you have
a chance to do things right to save
countless lives but this path cannot be
forced on you that's why we gave you a
taste of what could be the good that
could be done here and the response of
mark when they ask him will you stay
here do you want to stay on this world
do you want to basically continue
sparing lives right using your knowledge
of the past in order to ensure that
fewer people die the response of mark is
no and then like that's when the thing
is coming what
what they were expecting him to say yeah
and he's like i have a daughter and so
he says no if i have to choose this then
i'm saying no that's not going to happen
and that's when they're kind of like i
mean this this wasn't really this was
not foreseen uh you're pure right you're
selfless how can you turn this down and
he says even i will get together we'll
probably even have a child but there's
no way that child would end up being
terror choosing this means killing my
daughter and he says you would allow the
countless deaths that you could prevent
to occur just to save one life right you
know this thing's like you would let
millions and millions and millions of
people die to save the life of one
person and the response of mark is yes i
would and they're like how could we not
have foreseen this right like we knew
every single moment of your life you've
sacrificed so much for so many people
already you were our last hope and then
like in the end mark's like like last
hope for what right like you haven't
told me anything right you haven't told
me like who you are you haven't told me
what i'm preventing like this is all
just ridiculous right you put me through
hell and you think that i would just
choose to stay here he was like screw
this right like i mean that you haven't
given me a reason to want to stay here
and so ultimately this thing's like we
would be unable to explain to you what
we are at least what we're trying to
prevent in a way that you could possibly
comprehend and so this thing says like
it is true that taking our offer would
eliminate the existence of your daughter
knowing that we have only one question
for you is there anything we could say
to make you reconsider and the response
of mark is no and this thing says then
you have doomed this world you are a
disgrace and then just sends him back to
where it was that he came from and so
ultimately of course he's able to escape
that hole but when he gets out there
essentially all these ships that
that were like scouring the area where
like they were looking for thrag and all
that kind of stuff before he got yanked
down here they're all seemingly
destroyed right they're just like
crashed down here and it looks like
they've been there for a while
ultimately mark escapes the planet and
then races back to telesco to find adam
eve who of course is just kind of
chilling there and just sort of doing
her thing and then like when she sees
mark she's totally flabbergasted to see
him now here's the thing you wouldn't
think she would be because at this point
there have been multiple instances where
mark has been gone for months right for
like days or weeks or months it just
kind of goes with the territory and so
the reason why she's totally shocked
here to see him you know and where he's
just like oh my god like i'm you know
like i have to talk to you like these
creatures i was pulled through time and
like i was i was in the past and they
wanted me to change history and to like
to to choose like the death of of our of
of tara in order to like save that
reality like all these crazy things you
know he was like it's you know i i
couldn't i couldn't do that right like i
had to come back here i had to be with
you i had to be with our daughter you
know so she's like i mean are you okay i
mean it's like it's a lot to go through
mark like it's a lot to have happen you
know and he's like he's like i mean i'm
not i'm really not he was like but i
need to see tara right where is she like
i need to hold her i need to be able to
talk to her and she he's like you know
she's like mark i mean tara's inside but
there's something you have to understand
and that's when mark realizes the reason
why adam eve was so shocked to see him
is not because mark has been gone for
days or weeks or months it's because
mark's been gone
for years with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace
you